Start broadcast.
Hello World German.
We are alive.
We're alive,
live.
Welcome to the podcast,
Ryan,
Callan,
Eddie,
the twist of Bravo,
mad flavor,
Aka Ciotti as if it's
two in the afternoon.
If you ain't how I go,
fuck yourself.
Got On my face.
I want you around me like I want cancer,
my ball sack,
and I'm saying,
have you ever heard,
oh,
I fucking hate rant.
I don't know how the fuck people are gonna
eat that shit and see the blue cheese
with wings and go fuck your mother.
That's the next year.
All right,
please.
I knew you were going to give me
that slush plan a fucking week.
Look at my fucking eyes bled.
Look,
Heidi,
you got,
I tell the story now and stage.
The guy who used to drive us,
he started smoking and then he goes,
I can't drive unless I'm fucked up.
That's a quo
I want.
I'm going to put you on the Rogan.
Hold on a hey.
Have you ever watched her Rodeo
and felt sorry for the bowls?
No Sir.
He grew up extremely religious and they
told you when you masturbated that you
were impregnating a demon.
When you're doing it,
some demon comes and like,
she's like a round you fucking
you as you're fucking your hand.
Did you masturbate as anyway even knowing
all this [inaudible] you ever throw up
on a check?
No,
I did right as I was about to eat it
when I was like I had girlfriends
they'd sleep over and uh,
I would,
I would
kicks in the middle of the night like,
like my,
my whole body would choke like a kid
cause I was having a fighting drink.
That's the name of good
Bruce Springsteen album.
Make,
make my own spirit when I
threw kicks in the night.
Yeah.
Girl that was hot that
you were friends with.
You weren't somehow or another trying to
think how am I going to get the fucker?
My mother,
sorry,
the bad joke.
Sorry.
Duncan just went straight red band seven,
seven,
all of Guardian.
I think as a business,
the only way to protect herself
from like these like hacks,
like anonymous and stuff like that.
It's just to have a shitload of cats on
your website just because that's like
saying,
Hey,
I,
I'm on the Internet too.
I like cats and hamburgers and,
and what the fuck are you talking about?
All right.
You want me to explain it?
It says,
no,
definitely not.
A really bright retort at the
Faneuil hall comedy connection.
A black woman called the club and she say,
who wanted to show tonight?
And they said,
well,
it's Anthony Clark,
Jackie Flynn and Greg for 10 months.
And a lady goes,
is grapefruit Simmons the headliner
roll call?
He is your friend Joe Rogan
is the mom until Rhogam.
He's got the best damn podcasting.
I'm flashing forward here
at Joe About 30 years,
the year in the hills of
Colorado at this point,
podcast still going strong.
You're sitting there with a full beard,
like a full gray beard.
You're just waxing crazy poetic old man.
Talk,
lashing out against the government.
You're right next to me,
motherfucker.
So as a young comic working at
the Boston Comedy Club one night,
Tracy Morgan comes in,
he goes,
hey,
you want to get high?
And I was like,
yeah,
it gives it to me.
I hit it and it tastes like shit.
And I'm like,
what the fuck is this?
And he's like,
PCB who never smoked before.
And I'm like,
you just give me fucking
Igor opens the door.
And all I say to Igor in
Russian is I am the machine
lobby,
a single cell organism.
We're all having a good time down here.
The bottom of the ocean flow.
Anybody wants to change her?
You got to come through me.
I love being a carbon molecule.
All you freaks,
all you people out there at the gym,
all you people out there driving cross
country and sitting on trains were so
happy that you tuned into the show.
We'd love doing it.
We're happy you guys love it.
We've collected so many really cool and
friendly and fun people that follow us
and we just want you to know we love
all your dirty bitches were super,
super lucky man.
Having all these different guests on and
have it all these different people and
all these really different intelligent
people in a really intense opinions and
it's super,
super beneficial.
Man,
and I'm just so happy that
you were able to do this.
I is the fucking coolest
thing I've ever done.
I really,
really enjoy it.
I love you guys.
Thank you very much.
Bye.
Hit stop and see what it says.
I think stopped it.
See,
this is stopped.
Wait,
no.
He said,
stop.
Stop.
Broadcast.
Hit Stop.
Of course.
I said,
yeah.